three British men are being held in
Taliban custody in Afghanistan including
so-called danger tourist miles Rutledge
who returned to the country after being
evacuated by British armed forces less
than two years ago they're all believed
to have been held by taliban's secret
police since January in separate
incidents as Skies Lisa Holland reports
[Music]
in Afghanistan it was an extraordinary
sight an extraordinary moment after 20
years out of power
but whilst tens of thousands tried to
flee along with departing International
forces self-styled danger tourist miles
Routledge wanted to see for himself and
went in he was evacuated but returned
and it's emerged he's one of the three
britons being held by the Taliban the 23
year old has previously boasted to his
online followers that he travels to the
most dangerous places on Earth for fun
it's not known what led to his arrest
miles Routledge has been described as a
danger tourist seen here shooting a
Taliban weapon in Afghanistan last year
and the 23 year old from Birmingham is
now in the group's custody
gamble in order to benefit a little bit
why do you think I went to Afghanistan
to a quarter space there's risk and
there's a ward but
it's so much fun
huh
it's almost like actions have
consequences and this being
[__] around and found out
that's it end of the video
my question is or am I are you still
having fun yeah it's very [__] up for
me to like I'm not laughing at the dude
and everything and stuff I am but it's
very hard for me to have empathy no it's
very hard for me to have compassion yup
for stuff like stuff like that you mean
to tell me
you went over there right and a danger
tourists
right you went over there it's not your
job you just yeah followers and then the
British arm meme retrieved your whole
ass out of there because it was
dangerous and you said you know what
Mike let me put back in and then you put
back in and what happened was uh
uh yeah and I know I know
yeah my friend you have made the wrong
decision you have decided to go into the
lines then
and just before the lion is eating you
the first time these zookeeper has come
and saved you behind they have taken you
out of danger and they have said don't
go back inside and then you have said I
want to go back I Am Lord miles they
said you are going to be lorded and fly
soon if you continue this stupid
Behavior huh don't do it don't do it we
have gone and done it and then after you
have gone and done the thing that you
shouldn't have done that we have told
you not to do before but you did anyways
and you have paid the price you have
said please sir can I get a refund you
did not bring a receipt now you're going
to be eaten by the lion and we are going
to enjoy it yes I don't care if we are
going to spend one dime of government
money on saving you I will say the
government is irresponsible for you have
made your decision and it is not the
taxpayers job to save your stupid self
well why should I subsidize your
decisions you have gone and said no no
no you have gone out in the world and
you have decided I am you have decided
to risk your life you have risked it and
lost the bet now you have to pay the
money I am for that The Army Goes get
his ass again
hold on let me finish okay I am for the
Army the British army to go get his ass
only to find you fine only to find you
and to put you in front of a court
because that was deliberately in the
desert they don't shower very often
enjoy eating the poo poo there
because let me tell you the Afghani
people has to be dry then the wrist
I went shooting with the Taliban eight
months ago I wonder if he has posted
since then let's find out everyone is
Lord miles here I'm in Afghanistan on
forged documents going to meet a black
market gun Runner as you know guys today
is the anniversary of Italian bantego
but it's been exactly one year and guess
where it was last year right here as
well during the Takeover of all the time
and
meditate parades going on but there's
also further concerns about daesh Isis
is going to do an attack there so let's
go see what's happening today and we're
going to explore a little bit maybe see
some journalists interview some Taliban
I think it'll be a perfect opportunity
oh these Crowds Are huge are you guys
excited
well you look scared as everyone was
scared
the locals are scared but me
okay this is not a graphic detail you
guys want to know
but what do you guys think happens to
American soldiers when they get captured
it might be an Islamic country but let
me tell you there's some butt [__]
going on don't believe me you can look
up this set American soldiers will say
the same thing
them soldiers especially if you're in
the right spot they take it wait what
are you talking about what are you
talking about are you telling me that a
bunch of men in the in the in the
mountains for several months at a time
are gonna but other mans and people that
they capture is that what you're telling
me just say what what
just saying are you saying that this is
like a prison sentence is that what it
is Lord miles about to be Lord's keep
Lords keep
it I'm just saying we'll be chanting
oh it's not a chance okay
he's all over us
I have to emphasize this guys so I
conquered on this message of course and
I really do like America to all my
favorite countries so I don't condone
this message one bit you went to Taliban
parade saying I don't encourage or
endorse the message of killed Americans
who was previously wanted by the US for
five years I'm also going to hang out
with the Taliban
you may ask why am I in Afghanistan well
that's a really good question during
Kobe lockdowns Afghanistan was the only
country open without a vaccine mandate
no
no no no no no no no no no no no buddy
no no no no no no no no no no just get a
cabin in the woods
you're the only dumb [__]
that had this idea that is crazy out of
everybody that I know that's against all
of that you the only dumb [__]
that said to himself
[Music]
been here about 20 minutes to see what's
going on a few people apparently died
strapped between two Taliban groups
miles
standing there getting a free ride
[Music]
not go like that looks way more
comfortable than a lot of public buses
I've ridden on here in Canada oh yeah
it's fresh air in his eye yeah he's got
fresh air in space ain't nothing like
being on a bus and having somebody grind
against the side of your body oh you got
a pit Oh my days you ever skill and
smell [__] teenagers in full on
puberty yeah oh my God they're too poor
to afford deodorant apparently that's
why that's why I'm doing that yeah I
don't think no thank you
it's amazing how much is this 14 000
140 for this and how much will be ammo
and for a magazine yeah it's not cheap
by Afghan standards by American
Standards it's very cheap my friend over
here
Thai man there was some also locals in
his home Village which we can go
shooting with was very small cost so
it's going up to pick them up and uh
maybe we'll go shooting maybe I'll make
it thrown into a ditch we'll have to see
your life you always have to make a
gamble in order to benefit a little bit
why do you think I went to Afghanistan
in a corner space there's risk and
there's a ward but for me there's only
reward because it's so much fun let's do
some shooting with the Taliban
so we got someone from the Taliban over
here we've also got someone from local
Mafia lovely people and we're gonna
shoot some weapons this is your prize
right here
again yeah
oh I like this no get your head up
bigger
raping that what it oh wow
we both have the same life we shot a
Taliban
shot a [__] in the foot he shot
a [__] in the foot hand himself
in the foot God damn
yo this guy's so wild he was a time I
was like
foreign
thank you my friends maybe we do one
more yeah maybe just one more yeah
yeah
you you you're fighting yeah okay
very good be careful
yo [__] this guy [__] this guy is not
only an idiot a goober somebody but like
he's also dangerous to everyone right
[__] him okay that's enough does he
deserve death listen all hail the
Taliban kill this man great please put a
video up online I'll watch it and don't
say all hell what are you doing in this
situation
okay no no there's a bunch of criminals
who touch little kids and diddle them
send them out to Taliban how are you mad
I agree with that I think yeah
this guy two okay do us a favor let's
build some U.S Taliban relations oh my
God my guy I can say they're comfortable
he is crazy